hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
edit distance so this is a dynamic
programming problem and this is
very similar to the problem longest
common subsequence which is a problem
i've solved on this channel so
this problem is basically an extension
of that problem
so we're given two strings word one and
word two
and our goal is to return the minimum
number of
operations required to take word one
and convert it into word two and we only
have
three operations available to us
inserting a character
into word one right remember because
we're trying to take word one and
convert it
into word two we can't change word two
we can delete a character
from word one because we can't change
word two and we can replace a character
in word one and so replacing a character
is basically changing
one character into another so in this
case
there's three operations it would take
to take horse and turn it into
this string of course we'd want to get
rid of the
h right but we would do that by
replacing the h with an
r so this is going to be an r and then
we have
two r's right so we'd get rid of this r
so we
can get rid of that and lastly we see we
have
r o s we have an extra e so we're going
to get
rid of the e as well so we did that in
three operations
so we can return three so first of all
let's analyze some simple cases
what if we had the case where word one
and word two were both
just empty strings how many operations
does it take then to take word one and
convert it into word two
obviously zero right we don't have to do
anything they're already the same
similarly if word one was let's say abc
and word two
is also a b c we also
don't have to do anything right we'd
look at the first character see oh
they're the same right
since they're the same of course we
don't have to consider them anymore
right
then all we have to do is compare the
remainder of each string right but then
we see again hey b
is the same good c is also the same
good and look perfectly timed there's no
characters left in word one and there's
no characters left in word two
therefore zero operations were needed
right
what if word one was abc
and word two was empty then what would
we do is it even possible to take this
word and then convert it into an
empty of course it is in this problem
it's
always going to be possible to take word
one and convert it into word two right
because we can insert a character we can
delete a character
or we can replace a character so it's
always going to be possible
because in the worst case right this is
what we could do
we could take every single character in
word one and just delete it
delete that delete that because none of
these show up in word two
just delete all of them if there was
some character maybe there's a z over
here
then we could just copy every character
after we've deleted these
and then copy it over here right add
that z but no we don't need to
so my question to you is if word two is
empty
and word one is not empty then what's
this is a base case
how many operations is it gonna take is
always going to take the length of word
one whatever the length happens to be
because we're gonna have to delete
every single character right so that's
one base case word two is empty
what about the opposite case what if
word two was abc
and word one was empty is this possible
is it possible to take word one and
convert it to word two
of course it is right because we're
allowed to insert characters in here so
basically we could just read character
by character a
add that here b add that here c add that
here
as well right so we can just copy every
character so my question to you is in
in this case the opposite case where
word two is
non-empty but word one is empty how many
operations is it gonna take well we're
just gonna
copy each character in here right so in
this case it's gonna take the length
of word two that's how many operations
it's going to take right so basically
what i'm getting at is if
word one is empty and word two is
non-empty
then we're gonna return the length of
this as the minimum number of operations
if the opposite was true right maybe
this is empty but this is not empty then
we'd return the length of the non-empty
one if one of them is empty we're going
to return the length of the non-empty
string that's going to be the minimum
number of operations
this is important because this is our
base case so now let's try to brute
force this
how are we going to handle it well we're
going to have two pointers right we're
going to have one pointer
pointing at a character in word one and
a second pointer pointing at a character
in word two we're going to compare
character by character
so the the one case is what if they're
exactly equal
then what what is the sub problem then
right because we don't have to consider
these characters anymore
now we're dealing with the sub problem
of the remainder of the
of those strings so basically if i'm
calling the pointer in word one i and
i'm calling the pointer in word to j
if these characters are equal that means
we can basically say i plus one is the
new problem and
j plus one is the is the new problem in
word two right so
we're just shifting our pointers like
that so basically to summarize
if these characters are equal right at
the i and j
pointer basically what i'm saying the
characters are equal then we're just
going to increment i by 1
and increment j by 1. the number of
operations we had to do was exactly
zero right we didn't have to do anything
they were already equal we didn't have
to
modify word one at all to the next
character so our i
pointer is going to be over here our j
pointer is going to be here because we
incremented both of them by one so now
let's compare the characters
c and b are not equal right so now our
else condition condition is going to
execute and we don't know
we know we have three options we can
insert a character
delete a character or replace a
character from word one
but we don't know which one to do right
so let's just try
all three what happens if we insert
a character what character are we gonna
wanna insert over here
obviously we'd wanna insert the
character from word two we don't know if
that's going to end up making word one
exactly into word two in the minimum
number of operations but let's just try
it and see what happens
right so what would we do if we inserted
a c over here right we're not deleting a
character all we're doing is inserting a
c
over here in that case our i pointer is
still going to be pointing at this b
right
but since we inserted a c over here it's
hard to read
but let's say i inserted a c in between
over here
that means we took care of the c from
word two right so
basically we don't need to find a
matching c for it anymore we do need to
find a matching b
somewhere over here right so we're gonna
leave our i
pointer where it is but we're gonna take
our j pointer and then shift it to the
next position
in word two that's what we would do if
we inserted a character
so as you can see when we insert a
character
we are taking one operation right so
we're gonna have to add a one to the
number of operations we did
but when we when we shift our pointers
the i
pointer stays the exact same but j
is incremented by one so that's one
possibility
another possibility is we delete a
character so we're allowed to delete
characters from
our word one right so what would happen
if i just deleted this character what
we're saying is
okay i can't find a matching c in this
position right
and we and we don't have a b
corresponding to that position so i'm
just going to ignore this guy
and hopefully the remainder of the
strings can match up right so what i'm
saying is i'm going to take our
eye pointer and yes i am going to shift
it to the next position because i just i
want to pretend like this character
never existed but it does take one
operation to complete that but since we
did not
find a matching c yet right we have to
leave our j pointer here right we have
to keep searching until we find a
matching c
ultimately we want word one to match
word two
so in this case for the delete operation
what we're saying is i is going to be
shifted but j is going to stay the exact
same so i plus 1 but j stays the same
as you can see this is you know kind of
a pattern we're starting to see a
pattern right
and the last thing that we can do is
replace
a character from word one that shows up
in word two right obviously if we're
replacing a character from word
one right we're gonna want the character
that's matching
in word two right so what we'd wanna do
is take this b
and replace it with a c character right
if we did that clearly these two
characters match right we
made them match we forced these
characters to match
so in that case we we know that the c
has a matching c
up here so we can take this i pointer
and shift it and we can take our j
pointer and shift it to the next
position right so
the replace actually ends up doing the
exact same thing as
if the characters were equal and that
makes sense because what we're doing is
we're
forcing them to be equal with the
replace operation
the difference between the replace and
and if they were already originally
equal
is that the replace does take a single
operation if they were already equal
the number of operations it takes is
zero right
so it does come with a cost even though
replace is pretty powerful
as i said with replace what we're going
to do is increment i
and increment j so let's just go with
the replace operation because that's
actually going to end up
being the minimum solution so now we
shifted our pointers to the next
position we see
d and d they match each other so this is
the statement that's going to execute
and we know that takes 0
operations right so we're going to
increment both pointers by 1.
j is going to be over here now i is
going to be over here notice now how we
have two
empty strings remember the base case if
both strings are empty
we can return 0 because it takes zero
operations to make them
equal right they're already equal so
we're done we return
zero how many operations did it take by
the way if we
if you were counting we did have to
execute a single replace
operation that took one operation so the
result is
one so we are noticing that the sub
problems
are good to solve before we try to solve
the original
problem of comparing the entire lists
let me reformat this
into the dynamic programming explanation
so you may have seen something like this
before this is going to be a
two-dimensional dynamic programming
problem
it's good to visualize it kind of like
this so what we're doing here is we are
comparing these two strings
and for this position this is what we
want to calculate
in this position what we're going to do
is we're going to store
the basically the minimum number of
operations for
these two strings starting at this
character for word two
starting at this character for word one
so basically the entire strings
is going to be stored here what would be
stored in this position basically
corresponding to here so we're comparing
these two
basically the remainder of this string
and from here
the remainder of this string so in this
position what we would store
is the minimum number of operations it
would take to make this
sub problem these two sub strings how
many
minimum operations it would take to make
them equal
okay so that makes sense so far but then
why do i have this
extra layer over here the this
portion is for our base case what would
be over here
right so clearly we see that there's an
empty string over here there's an empty
string over here what value should i put
over here obviously zero right two empty
strings take
zero operations to make equal what about
in
this position what does this position
tell us well we have an empty string
from word two
but over here we have the entire string
from word one
so how many minimum operations would
that take remember we went over that at
the beginning
and it would just be the length of the
non-empty string so here we can see the
length of the non-empty string
is three what about in this position
similarly
word two is empty word one has a length
of
two so we'd put two and basically
continuing
to one and then down to zero right so
similarly over here
we have an empty string from word one
word two is completely
full and the length of it is three so
we're going to put three here
and then continue just counting down
three two
one right so in what order are we going
to solve this
if we start at the beginning then we're
going to notice something
notice okay well we're comparing these
two characters in this position right
they're both
equal right so then we're going to
execute this statement right so we're
going to take
i plus 1 and j plus 1. what does that
tell us that tells us that the result of
this value
depends on this value right
so okay then let's take a look at this
value well in this case they're
not equal b and c are not equal
so then what are we going to do remember
if they're not equal we have to brute
force it we have to take a look at all
three operations and remember i
corresponds to word one
j corresponds to or two so in the insert
operation what we're going to do is look
in this spot
in the delete operation what we're going
to do increment i by 1 in this case so
we're going to look in this spot
and for the replace operation we're
incrementing both of them so then we're
going diagonal
again from this since we have three
values that we're looking at what we're
going to do is we want to know which one
of these three
leads us to the minimum number of
operations right so what in reality
what we're going to do is since we're
noticing that
it depends on the lower values let's do
this
bottom up this is called bottom up
dynamic programming we're going to start
at the bottom
compute this value compute this value
compute this value
and then so on and so on and then work
our way backwards until we finally
get to the result and notice if we do
start
in this position we already have the
values that it could possibly depend on
because those are our base cases over
here
diagonally and below right and so notice
d and d are equal so what we're going to
do is from here we're going to look at
the diagonal value
right because this this statement is
going to execute we're going to see it's
zero
so that's what we're going to put over
here and then eventually we would end
we would compute these and then
eventually we would get up over
here right and we'd compute the value
from that
and then eventually we'd get all the way
up here and we would compute the value
from here you would see that we'd end up
putting a 1 over here we'd end up
putting a 1
over here so what would the value over
here end up being well let's look at the
two characters d
and c they're not equal so what we're
going to do is we're going to look down
we're going to look
diagonal and we're going to look to the
right which one of those values is
minimum
it's over here so that's 0 but we do
have to add 1 because
in this case we do need to do a single
operation so we add 1
and similarly is what we would do for
every single position
you know we'd compare the characters and
then we'd execute this statement or we'd
execute
this statement so i'm not going to run
through that but i think this is simple
enough that if you want to you can get a
piece of paper out
and then try it for yourself and you'll
probably come to the same conclusion
so that being said let's jump into the
code this is exactly what i'm going to
do with the code i'm going to have a two
dimensional
array and i'm going to execute these
exact statements
so i'm going to call our two-dimensional
array our cache
and so basically i'm going to initialize
it to
initial values of just max integer or
float infinity in python
and you can probably initialize this any
way that you'd like in your own language
there's probably
a different ways that you'd want to do
that but i'm going to use
a list comprehension so basically i'm
creating a list
fl with float infinite as the value of
length
word two plus one remember because we do
need to make
our two dimensional array a little bit
bigger to handle those base cases
for this list i'm gonna have one of
these lists basically for every
character
in the range of the length of
word one so this probably looks
confusing if you're not familiar with
python but basically i'm just creating a
two-dimensional array
with these dimensions actually word one
the length of board one plus one
because remember we are worrying about
the base case but basically yeah
a two dimensional array so now i wanna
fill up
our bottom row of the two-dimensional
grid
so what i'm gonna do is for our cache
i'm going to go to the bottom row what's
the bottom row it's going to be the
length of the word
1 and that's going to be the bottom row
and we're going to go through every
value of it so for
every j of that remember where it's
going to be basically
in descending order so what i'm going to
do is and it's going to initially start
at the length of what word two happens
to be
because remember the base case is if one
string is empty and the other string
isn't so word two and it's going to
basically be decrementing by one each
time so what i can just do is just say
length of word two dec subtracted by
j and actually i keep forgetting the
bottom row is actually not just going to
be the length of word tube that's going
to be length of word two plus
one so i want to make sure to add that
plus one and similarly what we're gonna
do is and for that right most column
what we're gonna do is go through every
position in it so length of word one
plus one and for every work every
position in
the last column and the last column can
be
found like this basically for every i
in the last column which is going to be
length of word
2 in this case and what we're going to
do is similar to what we did
up here take what the original length of
word one is
and each time subtract it by an
additional value
basically we can use i in this case so
this might be a little bit confusing
you can do this a bunch of different
ways if this is confusing to you you can
probably find your own way to do it
basically we're just initializing the
base case of our two dimensional array
but so now let's actually get into the
dynamic programming portion so remember
this is going to be bottom
up so we're going to work our way
backwards from the length of
word one minus one and the reason we're
minusing one is we know we already
filled up our base case
portion so now we actually want to get
to the actual dimensions of our two
strings
and we're going to do this in
decrementing order until we get
to the beginning until we get to the
zeroth index which is when this is going
to end up stopping
and similarly let's work our way
backwards from the length
of word to so we're going to start at
the bottom row and work our way
backwards and then keep doing that until
we end up getting to the top
row and remember we had two cases either
word one
at index i is equal to word two at
index j basically with the characters
that we're comparing are equal or
they're not equal remember if they are
equal
then that's really easy for us right
because then we can just say okay
cache of position i j what we're doing
here is computing what's the minimum
number of operations it would take
to get the sub string starting at i and
the substring starting at j for these
respective words
compute the minimum number of operations
so we can get that in this case since
the characters are equal just by saying
cache of i plus one cache of j plus
one and the else case is where we have
to check all three directions
and then take the minimum of those so
what i'm gonna do is say one
plus the minimum of those three uh
directions so cache of
i plus 1 and leave j the same
and also we want to take the minimum of
cash
of i left the same but j plus 1
and last but not least we want to take
the minimum of cash of i plus 1
and j plus one so this is a long line
but i'm going to leave it as it is
but yeah basically this is taking care
of insert delete
as well as replace and it's taking the
minimum of whatever
those were adding one to it because we
are having to do at least one operation
whichever one of those it is and then
storing that minimum
here and once we have done that once
we've filled up our entire
two-dimensional array
we want to return the value at index
0 0 of our cache because that tells us
what's the minimum number of operations
for the beginning of both strings so
basically the entirety
of both strings so this is definitely a
doozy of a problem it's not a ton of
code but it does take some thought to
get to here
and it's definitely an extension of
longest common subsequence
so i recommend solving that problem if
you haven't already
but i do hope that this was helpful it's
a tough dynamic programming problem
if it was helpful please like and
subscribe it supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching